i recently built a chat app that can
handle thousands of messages per second
scales around the world and cost me
nothing to run but the real weird thing
about it is that the data and
infrastructure is not controlled by a
big tech company instead it's
decentralized across the entire user
base using web technologies in fact you
can chat with me right now on the live
demo by going to gunchatdap.web.app
again that's
gunchatdap.web.app and i'm trusting you
not to hack it to pieces this time in
today's video we'll build a
decentralized chat app or dap if you
prefer similar to youtube super chat
using a library called gun js in the
process you'll learn about the benefits
of building a decentralized app along
with the weird trade-offs and challenges
for the front end ui we'll use svelt a
javascript library that's not sponsored
by big tech if you're new here like and
subscribe and you'll find the full
source code on github then i want to
give a shout out to mark nadal the
creator of gun js who donated a bunch of
his time to answer all my questions and
help make this video happen before we
jump into the code let's first answer
the question of how does this thing
actually work i made a short video about
gun js a few weeks ago and you guys had
a ton of questions about it at a high
level gun js is a decentralized graph
database a normal database would store
all of your data in a hard disk
somewhere in the cloud it may be sharded
across multiple machines but for all
intents and purposes you can imagine
your entire data set on a single disk
gun on the other hand stores a small
subset of data on each user based on the
actual data that they consume in the
application when a user makes a query
for some data it will search across the
network for other users that have that
data and sync it up using technologies
like webrtc so you can think of the
entire database as the union of all
peers on the network the idea is very
similar to a blockchain ledger where no
one individual has control of the entire
network but it's important to point out
that this is not blockchain technology
which tends to be too slow and just
unnecessary to build something like a
super chat however it does rely heavily
on cryptography to implement things like
user authentication when you create a
new user account a cryptographically
secure key pair is generated the
username is associated with a public key
so past messages can be found and the
password is a proof of work seed to
prove and decrypt access to the
account's private keys in addition it's
possible to implement end-to-end
encryption which we'll do in this demo
but we'll talk more about that later in
the video another good question is how
is data persisted and what happens if a
user just clears out their browser cache
by default data is stored in the
browser's local storage which is limited
to 5 megabytes and if a user clears out
the data in local storage it could
potentially be lost if it's not
somewhere else on the network that's
probably not acceptable if you're
building a production grade app but what
you can do is deploy a relay server that
uses a different storage mechanism
called radix that can store a lot more
data on the disk of an actual server and
that makes the network more robust
because a query can fall back to a relay
if it's not available from another peer
now another really important concept to
understand is that when you create a
node in the database it'll be available
to the entire decentralized network that
means another developer can easily
access your public data by simply
knowing the name of the node where it's
stored now it is possible to encrypt
data and things like that but it just
requires a completely different mental
model than you might be used to let's go
ahead and jump into the source code i'm
not going to cover every single line of
code in this project and instead just
focus on the important parts related to
the database what we have here is a
spelt app with two main features email
password user authentication and then a
massive group chat room that anybody can
join the only dependency in this project
is gun which can be installed with npm
the first thing we'll focus on is user
authentication and to do that i'm
creating a file called user.js at the
top of the file we'll import gun and
below that import two supporting
libraries the first one c which stands
for security encryption and
authorization and is the module that
enables user authentication next we have
ax which stands for advanced exchange
equation and is basically an alternative
way to connect peers together and tends
to be more performant for a chat app
like this and there's a whole dock on it
if you want to learn more from there
we'll create a variable called db to
initialize the database then we'll use
it to make a reference to the currently
authenticated user i'm also chaining the
option of recall to session storage here
so the user stays logged in between
browser sessions now to manage the user
in the app we need to know if the user
is logged in and we also want their
username so we can show it in the ui we
can get the username by making a
reference to the user then calling git
alias which will be the value of
whatever username they choose when they
sign up now we're going to use this
value frequently throughout the
application so i'm importing writable
from spelt store to make it reactive a
store is like an observable value that
will re-render the ui whenever it's
changed and it can be shared across
multiple components so whenever the
alias for the current user updates we'll
set the value of the store to that value
but we also want to listen to changes to
the auth state when the user signs in or
signs out to handle that we'll listen to
the auth event on the database and
basically do the same thing here where
we fetch the alias and then set that as
the value on the store now i'm going to
kind of do things in reverse here
because i first want to show you how the
store works in spelt we have this header
component here that will show the title
of the app if you're not logged in but
if you are logged in it'll show your
username as well as your avatar now
implementing sign out is really easy all
we have to do is import the username
store and the gun user object then we'll
create a function called sign out that
calls leave on the user and sets the
username store to an empty string then
down in the html we have a button that
when clicked we'll call the sign out
function but we only want to show that
button if the user is signed in and the
way we can tell if a user is signed in
is if their username is present the cool
thing about svelt is that we can easily
do that with a store in any component by
adding an if statement followed by a
dollar sign and then the name of the
store the dollar sign will subscribe to
the store and react to any changes that
happen to it if the username does exist
then we'll go ahead and show the
username by subscribing to the store
once again we can also do the same thing
to show an avatar with the user's
initials by using the awesome dicepare
api i made a short video about this
already but dicebear will basically make
a unique avatar based on the username as
the random seat then after that we have
a button that fires the sign out
function when clicked and finally we'll
add an else block here to show something
else if the user is not logged in that
takes care of the header component and
you'll notice that i'm declaring it here
in the app component and now we can move
on to the login component that will
allow the user to sign in or sign up
with their username and password in the
component we'll import the user object
then set up local state for the username
and password in svelt we can implement
two-way data binding with a variable by
creating a form input and then saying
bind value to that variable that means
anytime the user types into the form the
value of the variable will change we
have separate form inputs for username
and password and we'll share them for
both the login and signup process which
itself just consists of two different
buttons that will either call the login
function or the sign up function to log
a user in we use the user auth method it
takes the username and password as
arguments then the third argument allows
you to define a callback in this case
the value of the store that we set up
earlier will update automatically but we
can do other things here as well like
error handling now the process to sign
up a new user is very similar but
instead of calling auth we call that
create method on the user and if the
user creation is successful then we will
log that user in automatically now at
this point we have a working user
authentication system but one thing to
keep in mind here is that we're not
enforcing the uniqueness of the username
which is just a caveat you'll want to
keep in mind i should mention that it is
possible to enforce username uniqueness
but it's beyond the scope of this video
now we can move on to the chat component
which is where we will query items from
the database and also give the user the
ability to send a message the component
has two pieces of state a string for a
new message that the user will type into
a form input and an array of messages
which will contain the message text
along with the user who sent it and a
time stamp to query messages i'm going
to set up the on mount lifecycle hook
that will run whenever the component is
first initialized inside of it we'll use
the database to make a reference to the
chat node in this demo since we have one
giant super chat we can just give it a
name of chat but if you have multiple
chat rooms you'd likely want to give
each one a different name after that
we'll call map to basically loop over
every single message in the chat and
then call once to only read each message
once in this case each message is
immutable so we don't need to listen to
changes in real time but you could do
that if you wanted to using the on
method we can then define a callback
that will be called on each new message
that will give us access to the data and
the id of that node now if the data is
defined we're going to format a message
that's more suitable for the ui with the
properties of who what and when who is
the user that sent the message and we
can figure out who sent it by taking
that data of the raw message and using
it to get the alias next we have what
which is the actual text of the user's
message but the interesting thing here
is that we're actually implementing
end-to-end encryption that means the
value in the database is encrypted and
the only way to decrypt it is to have
the corresponding key in this demo our
data is encrypted but it's not really
secure because i'm just hard coding the
encryption key right here in the source
code so anybody could find it but if it
was an actual secret between two users
you could use it to encrypt and decrypt
messages and finally we have the win
property to get an accurate timestamp
across all of our users we're using gun
state as the final source of truth with
the raw data that'll give us all the
data we need for the ui then the final
step is to take each message and add it
to an array that we can then loop over
in the ui with spelled you can loop over
an array of items in svelt with each
this will render the chat message
component for each message in the array
and also notice how i'm adding
parentheses with message win which
provides felt with a unique key to sort
all of the messages efficiently that
gives us a way to read messages in the
chat now we just need a form to submit
them in the ui you'll notice that i have
a form that on the submit event we'll
call the send message function inside
the function the first thing we'll want
to do is use c to encrypt the actual
message text and notice how the key is
the same as the one we used earlier to
decrypt the messages from there we can
associate the message to the current
user using the encrypted message as the
value then we'll create a date to serve
as the index for the message so it can
be sorted properly at which point we can
reference the chat collection create a
new node based on that index and store
the message value congratulations you
just built a decentralized chat app
it'll be interesting to see if this
thing actually works when the video is
released let me know how things go for
you in the comments make sure to like
and subscribe thanks for watching and i
will see you in the next one